here's a little exercise you can use
right now
to enhance your creativity what we're
going to do is we're going to overcome a
cognitive bias
which is called functional fixedness
cognitive biases
are flaws in our thinking errors in our
thinking that cause us to think uh
incorrectly um about certain subjects
it's kind of like a shortcut a brain
takes which might be useful in some
circumstances but it can end up getting
us into trouble
so in this case functional fixedness
means that you think of an item you have
only in terms of what that item can do
so
say i've got this book by brian cox
um functional fixes this is what's
making me think of it as a book as
opposed to
paper and card
for the cover so how can that prevent
you from being
creative well the uh example that
psychologists use is something called
the candle experiment or the candle box
experiment i can't remember so basically
you have a candle
and you have a box of tax and someone
will say to you
hey use this box of tax in this candle
and
get the candle to attach to the wall so
that it can burn whilst being attached
to the wall
like a nice little lamp and so most
people will take the candle they'll take
the tacks and they'll try
attacking the candle to the wall which
doesn't work because it will just break
the wax and make a mess and also
unless you're superman you can't just
push attack into a wall through a candle
so what they're supposed to do is to
take the box that the tacks are in
and attach the box to the wall and then
stand the candle in the box
the problem is they can't think of the
box as a container or a shelf because
they're actually thinking of it
as a box for the tax that's functional
fixedness and it's preventing them from
being as creative
as they can so how do you get around
this what you have to do is you have to
take everything you've got and you think
of it in terms of resources
as materials as opposed to whatever it
is they're supposed to be
so in this in the case of the candle box
experiment you would have uh wax you'd
have wick you'd have which is sort of
string
you'd have uh um cardboard you'd have
metal tacks box candle all those things
there's all the resources you have
available to you
and if you look at things like this you
realize you have more resources you
become more resourcefulness you overcome
that cognitive bias
and you can come up with more out there
solutions to your problems
next time someone gives you a tongue
twister try using this exercise and you
might find
you're able to come up not a tongue
twister or a riddle you might find
you're able to come up
with the solution um so that's
functional fitness that's one example
of the way our brain can sometimes
prevent us from thinking creativity
creatively
so what is creativity creativity is the
ability to
lean back and to allow yourself to
explore the interconnected ideas
through the web of your connected
neurons so everyone in their brain has
got billions of connections
lots of little brain cells neurons all
connected by little tendrils
um and they have these gaps which they
communicate between called synapses
this big web would look like a massive
mind map if you were to
somehow draw it down and it's called
your connectome
your connecting stores all your ideas or
your beliefs your opinions your memories
and it's what makes you who you are to a
large extent
so when you're creative you lean back
and you let your brain explore
kind of bleed outwards and look at all
these different interconnected ideas
and find novel connections and
correlations between things that perhaps
wouldn't obviously be connected
so in other words you're taking old
ideas and recombining them to create
new ones as opposed to just looking at
the obvious connections
so what you need to do in order to do
this is relax your brain
and a lot of nootropics and a lot of you
know things like caffeine
they're all about focus and energy and
being highly wired so that you don't get
distracted but actually that's not what
you want
if you want to be creative you want to
be creative you need the opposite you
need to relax
because when you're focused when you've
got lots of dopamine and norepinephrine
in your brain
you're wired your focus is on one thing
that's going on in your brain at once
well it's not really one thing but lots
of things
but it's it's more it's one thing when
you're relaxed and laid back and you're
on the verge of sleep your brain is
exploring all these different ideas
in fact as you're starting to fall
asleep you hit the hypnagogic state
which is the point where you're just
before sleep where your thoughts start
to make
no sense and that's because of melatonin
and gaba and things that make your brain
more relaxed that's why using marijuana
or alcohol can actually increase your
creativity not that i suggest that you
use either of those
in order to improve your creativity i
actually really don't
however there are lots of other things
you can do to make your mind more
relaxed to help yourself
wander through the networks of your mind
and come up with new ideas
one example is simply just to relax um
and studies have shown that having green
in the room like a plant can actually
make you
more relaxed and thus more creative the
reason for this is that we associate
from an evolutionary perspective the
color green with
natural environments that are full of
resources so we enjoy them so we feel
more relaxed
when we're in them likewise you can feel
more relaxed by going for walk
and many studies have shown that walks
are fantastic for creativity and they
increase
our ideas and our inventiveness many
good ideas come as well
when you're not forcing them when you're
in the shower this is when you're able
to
activate your default mode network the
default mode network is the part of your
brain that kicks in
when you're not doing anything it's when
you go introverted and again this is my
problem with people
assuming that certain neurotransmitters
are better than others
everyone's talking about flow states and
how good they are for being productive
and creative etc but flow states are all
about being engaged with your
environment that's great
but um even einstein would say that the
reason he counted the theory of
relativity
was that he was working in the painting
office at the time actually came with
the special
theory of relativity when he's in the
patent office not that's important right
now
point is that you can distract your high
order thinking with
something mundane you're able to
you just you distract the other part of
your brain with something mundane
you're able to uh turn inwards start
thinking about things
without any distractions using your
default mode network that you use to
imagine different scenarios and explore
ideas and get created
so this is one good reason to maybe turn
off youtube or those podcasts when
you're washing up the dishes
and instead just let your mind wander
there's a lot of value in just letting
your mind wander
i also mentioned how being on the verge
of sleep was great
exploring different ideas in your mind
because of the hypnagogic
state that you go into and some
creatives actually try and use this
as a way to generate ideas people like
salvador dali i think
i think it was him who used something
similar to falling asleep
holding a spoon over a plate so he'd go
to sleep like that holding his spoon
over his plate and when he dropped off
to sleep he dropped the spoon he'd land
on the plate and make such noises wake
him up
what this meant was he would wake up
just as he was in that hypnagogic state
and that way he'd be able to remember
all of his ideas and
crazy things that he come up with and
that's why you painted such bizarre
stuff because it was all
from that part of his brain uh when it
was just one
wondering through different
interconnected ideas that he had stored
of course you also can get ideas from
your dreams
which pretty much is just your brain
randomly exploring around things
forming connections that's made during
the day but at the same time allowing
you to experience
completely bizarre combinations of ideas
people who are fortunate enough to be
able to lucid dream
they can use this as a creative process
as well unfortunately i'm not one of
them
as hard as i try i can post it on that
is something i am
interested in there are many other
things you can do to relax your brain
and to encourage this sort of thinking
but the point is whatever strategy you
use
sometimes just let your brain wander
through different ideas
and so there you go there's much more to
it than that of course but that is the
fundamentals explained when it comes to
creativity
and neuroscience creativity is about
letting your mind relax it's about
switching off those stress hormones that
make you so focused and agitated
and it's about just exploring different
ideas it's about the default mode
network
and it's about having rich environments
and rich inputs to give you lots of
things
to recombine into new ideas i hope you
found that useful and interesting i'd
love to hear your comments on what makes
you
uh get your creative juices flow and
stay tuned for more videos like this as
well as the usual fitness training etc
until next time bye for now